gang real quick before we get this
episode started summer is going into
full swing and so is the
are you garbage keep it moving 20 21
tour oh yeah we're gonna be coming to a
town near you
for a little bit of stand up and we're
gonna be answering your
garbage questions kippy tell them what
they need to know
yeah guys on uh june 22nd we'll be in
chicago still a few tickets left for
that
uh june 23rd we'll be in indy helium get
tickets for that and then buddy we're
all over the place
july 14th columbus funny bone july 15
cleveland hilarities august 11th rhode
island comedy connection
august 12th left boston those tickets
are cooking that's going to sell out
get those tickets then august 25th we're
at new brunswick stress factory and then
august 26th we're at magooby's joke
house in timonium
maryland right outside of baltimore i
like it gang get some ticks
come out and see it's going to be a
fantastic fun time come out and hang
with uncle hank and your aunt kippy
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is r.u
garbage it's a little show we sit down
with your favorite comedians and we
found out they grew up to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host holy coming at you
on a solemn day down here at antoni's
basement very upset about the sixers
yeah she had a lot of cash on that
[ __ ] game yeah she's spending a
patreon money
she's spending the patreon money too
much and speaking of spending patreon
money this guy's got a brand new
hawaiian shirt every day
he is the ceo of ru garbage he's the
head bozo around here so show him a
little respect give it up for kippy
kevin james ryan hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate you subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are
true to roof through the roof uh then
patreon.com as well you sign up your
bonus episodes the whole nine yards you
already know the spiel
live shows coming up get tickets we're
tanking here
and how about a quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man he
makes us all look good
he's got the place balanced out real
nice got some pro equipment
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby
mcmullen what's up dudes what's up
t-bone uh b h
on the phone trying to get this return
off dude
trying to get a customer service win
over here i like it yeah we got to
return some gear
yeah but gang we could not be more
excited to have our incredibly special
guest
here with us today back with us today we
got a little company
in the house we got a little star power
in the house he's going to answer your
questions
do me a favor give it up for the one the
only mr j
lawrence what's up boys mr larson in in
the flight
to be here you got out the uh get out
the nice
tin yeah i mean it's a sewing kit
actually in there
dude that's what everybody did that is
not even
you know what the other sign was the the
if it was a nice night
is those uh the uh little andes candies
the chocolate with the mint
laid out like in rows that literally
would come out after dinner on the table
like all right it's a game changer yeah
those things
we only broke those out on thanksgiving
it's the only time you saw in andy's
candies
and someone brought them it's not like
you guys yeah you want you didn't have
them in stock at the foley household
you split a pack of m ms if you want uh
came in very very
under under uh under impressed yeah yeah
i thought this was a studio i mean the
table's rocking and rolling
he's a big guy my chair is about to go
it went
it went yesterday actually this was a
set of six then you're down to three
fully goes through i ate the leaf in the
middle
[Laughter]
buddy thanks so much for coming back and
and hanging out with us oh yeah man
great to be here
uh when we did your episode if you
haven't seen jay's episode go back and
check it out it's [ __ ] absolutely
amazing and an authority on class
you turned already on youtube you blew
our hair back
i was like yeah going into it i'm like i
know he's classy but your attention to
detail on things
second to none you know that's just how
i do it you know what i mean we like it
yeah uh we wanted to open up with this
actually yeah uh we had a little debate
last episode we had a
somebody reached out to us and asked us
he's throwing his first party like his
first adult don't get
not like [ __ ] you know coke and
whatever um not a kegger
yeah he's doing his first get-together
with friends and he was asking us advice
on what are some do's and don'ts what
are some must-haves if you're if jay
larsen's throwing how many people are we
talking
about 12 people everybody's 25 to 35.
all right no solo cups that's one no
we said big solar problems i totally get
100 i say
no solo cup that's the right car that
was the first thing we bought
i got the blue ones too to show them i
had a little bit of cash you're supposed
to be an adult here what are we doing
you use glass
and you tell people he probably doesn't
have a dishwasher right
don't worry just put it next to the sink
i got it later you know what i mean but
how are you going to go through all
those glasses you got 12 15 people
you're not going to have 30 glasses
what do you mean you need new glasses
every time you need a drink i mean you
got 12 people
12 glasses also you can go classes
aren't expensive
you came in on a level of class so we
sat here and debated this yesterday for
30 minutes
never once out of actual glass listen
i'm also a glassware guy you know what i
mean i like glassware i have everything
you need a cordial i got it you need a
high ball i got it you need a martini
glass
i do them in an old school coop i do
them in a coupe glass you can also do
champagne in the coop so if you got
something what's the cooper rocks glass
no
coop is like you know that's what they
drink in the gatsby they like they
go like they look like a bowl and
they're on a stem so it's only like that
deep
they're like champagne jaws yeah that's
what you do like that's called a coop
you know what i mean so if you if you go
someplace nice they'll bring you in
manhattan and
i've got manhattans in a coupe yeah if
someone brings it to you in this get the
[ __ ] out
that's what you want so depending on who
it's going to be you know what'd you
tell them about beer what's a beer said
you got to be you got to have a booze
for everything this is what we were
saying
right would you this was one of the
things would you reach out and say hey
what's everybody drinking what do you
like
okay wow the first thing
i was so opposed to that yeah you don't
you you're entertaining you know what i
mean you don't like oh no dude should i
second guess and wonder
am i making the right decision shut up
[ __ ]
horses hot folks i'll tell you the hot
one
you know what you need you need some
i'll just tell you this guys
what are we doing i got a buddy who's a
restaurateur right and i love it
of course he's got a great aesthetic
he'd like the aesthetic here too
you're the first guy in here that's ever
said the word establishment that's where
you're coming in
you know what you know i thought that
was the guy that put you to sleep before
surgery
but i'm at this like i like to go to
like vintage antique marts you know what
i mean
and i look for old coops because they're
hard to find this guy's classy but uh
they have this like these uh
european baby they're like little tubs
they're like this long
this wide they round out and they're on
a stand like that right
and i looked at it and i'm like oh this
is perfect for my boy he's got
uh beer and wine bars i got like three
of them you do this for events you fill
it with ice you put wine in and the
beers
it's 300 bucks i grabbed a photo i
texted my buddy i'm like you want this
and he goes i don't need it but yeah i
want it i'm like done i'll have it at
the house
so i think you got to have a container
out you have maybe two whites you know
we're in the summer right
so you're gonna i would do a rose you
gotta have a rose out
back it up in the fridge don't let them
know you got it
and you put the cheaper one in the
fridge
i'm not saying go crazy i'm thinking
11.99 for your
your rose okay but if you look for the
advantages see like you got to be classy
but have trash in your veins that's what
i am
so i go to like a grocery store that if
you buy six bottles of wine you get 20
off you know what i mean so then you get
the 16.99 you get them down around
13. you know what i'm saying pretty good
so i get a couple roses i get a couple
whites
and then i'd have two reds and i'd have
them out and i'd have a little section
set up for cocktails so i'd
just have your basic i'd have a nice
whiskey for the fellas if they want to
go over what are you thinking what's
what are you getting
people coming over you don't want to
flex too hard where are you going
whiskey i mean my favorite sipping
whiskey is basil hayden that's my
favorite it's simple it's it's 80 proof
it's not like 92
96. you know what i mean i'm not doing
jack or bean or something
i'm a jmo guy myself all right well
you're talking irish yeah you know what
i mean so you could do that you know
jaymen's good or you want to do mcallen
or something like that what about
southern comfort
soco i i'd probably shelf that that's
that's for when everyone leaves and it's
you and your boys and you're like should
we do a couple shooters or what you know
so dude the way he said you should
probably shelf that
oh what about prosecco or cava does that
stuff hold on i throw a bottle of
prosecco in there yeah white claws any
of that [ __ ]
i'm not i'm that's you know what i mean
i've i think i'm out
i out aged that generation she's a
little young that's what everybody's
doing though
no sugar no carbs i might throw in a
hard kombucha
you can go zero sugars you know what i
mean
that's what i roll with man it's like my
wife's vegan friend
yeah well like you could have a hard
kombucha you could have your truly or
whatever yeah yeah yeah
white claw and then i'd have like two
beers i'd like do something to show that
you're you're hanging with the brooklyn
cats and either do like a a pbr or a
mill
light or i like pacifico in a canyon
i never had it in a cave in a can it's
nice and then what's your other beer
and then i would do like an ipa or
something like that yeah yeah that was
going to be my question was a big debate
we had where we were saying a couple
craft beers
and then you have the back up bud light
miller light something in the fridge
for when it when people don't want to
keep drinking that heavy [ __ ] when you
go to a dope liquor store
they'll let you go in and mix and match
yeah you could go you can get like your
white cloth six-pack or 12-pack then you
can get like a
the you know the pacifico and then you
can boom boom boom
a couple of these couple of those call
it a night if you do
i'm not saying you ask ahead of time but
if you got a friend who's dating like an
irish guy or something like that you get
a four pack of guinness
guys know who's coming you know what i
mean you are of course so far are you
going limes in the pacific oh
i would put a lime out on a cutting
board or i would never pre-cut they're
going to dry out
i would put out the lime with a knife
for people to do their own thing because
then people might make a gin and tonic
you know i mean
they want to do their own thing are you
mixing any drinks and having like
something like that you want to do a
house
a sangria pitcher i'm saying if you want
to do a house cocktail always a nice
touch you know what i mean you want to
do every house cocktail
and then you pre-make it you put it out
and then you just put like a little card
hey this is what this is you know like
uh
the the foley frenzy it would be like
soco coke zero
[Laughter]
but you could do some cheese
stuffed blue cheese olives in it you oh
those are great
yeah but i have been to parties where
they do do the house cocktail and it's
not a hit it's not good and they're
pushing it on you all night like hey try
these
and you're like come on these things
stink no one's touching it too much too
many apples in that [ __ ]
yeah stop with the [ __ ] putting it is
a nice touch if you do it right it's
fantastic i did do at my wedding you
know what i mean we did do a house
cocktail at my wedding like what was it
it was like a
it was a mint arnold uh arnold palmer
nice
i mean so it was loser just yeah yeah
and uh people liked it you know what i
mean and it's just simple people like to
be it gives you a thing to make people
part of the experience yeah when people
first show up like can i get some drink
let me give you the house cocktail you
don't get you don't put a giant glass
you don't
try it and just let them try it you
don't push it on them and then let them
go mint's really classy
mint really adds a lot of fresh mint oh
yeah
what did you guys suggest to him for
like apps or food i want i want to get
to that but i want to ask you this first
yes because i was getting breadsticks
from pizza
the good stuff the good ones extra
marinara
these bozos were saying and let me okay
let me rephrase this
under any circumstances okay you have a
garage fridge at your place
no okay if you did okay would you be
having the people
go into the refrigerator to get anything
no that's why i said you should have
like a
a tin you know what i mean like a big
container right you put ice and water
and wine beers stuff like that okay so
no garage fridge
the the refrigerator in your house would
you
put beers in the crisper and let people
grab them out of there
exactly the crisper for me is for like
lettuce and [ __ ]
i would go bottom shelf and i'd back it
up so it looks like a like a hotel
straight back it's it's like boom this
is that this is that this is that
thank you but like for me the first
party i think we had in la is like a
married couple before i was divorced is
we
i built a bar out of wood and i got an
old
sink that i bought like a steel you know
those ones that are painted white and i
dropped that in the bar then you packed
that with ice
and everything was in there and i had
shelves with all the liquor
and then just rows of glasses so that
you just and i had a bowl of fruit
so that you cut up whatever your fruit
choice was you know what i mean did you
make this thing just for the party
yeah yeah god damn i did our
thanksgiving out there i built the
tables
for our thanksgiving dinner you know
what i mean this guy's here he came to
[ __ ] play
dude he's pro we're out here tossing
minor league answers this guy's on the
yankees we're on the taluka wombats
appetizers yeah what'd you guys throw
out adam kevin
i said i said that i would have the
grill going in some capacity but we also
said okay let's say he lives in an
apartment doesn't have a grill that's
what we also said
so it's like you don't have to serve a
dinner i feel if it's like uh 12 people
you definitely don't need to serve a
dinner exactly yeah so it's like hey you
haven't got to have enough apps to keep
people going
yep you know what i mean we said like a
charcuterie board
um the hummus the guac the chips and
guac comments
am i making the guac no i i i'm getting
it we live in new york i mean i make the
quad
what is you living with in new york
capital i'm saying you can go get like
i could go get a guac anywhere i know
yeah we got avocados here what are you
talking about but i'm saying i'm not
buying like the pre-package thing that's
been sitting there for three i'm getting
the fret like there's like the grocery
stores that have the fresh stuff yeah
i'm grabbing the freshies
that's what i'm saying i'm spending a
couple of bucks okay yeah patreon's
doing all right i'm getting a fresh guac
are you tossing in a bowl pass it off as
your own
yeah of course i'm big on that played
everything no but he's saying are you
saying it you made it
i would never say i made it cause you
know who would do that my mother and my
sister like oh yeah and you're like
really what are you saying
when did you start making thai food it's
like [ __ ]
trash is stacked with boxes i swear to
god
delivery guy's still in the driveway
miss larson these chalupas are delicious
it's an old family recipe for real
they do that yeah my mom one time i had
sickler me and cichlid went home in a
mess
yeah shout out to sickle cell shout out
i don't know if i told the story
of the first time but we go home to my
mother's house and my mother's like i
made this
i made a completely fresh meal for you
guys
and she's like ryan come look and she's
like now i've been cooking my meatballs
i've been cooking all day
and that's in a homemade sauce and then
i have i go that's a homemade sauce
and she goes yeah i'm like all right and
she goes and then there's an eggplant
parm she goes not my recipe and it's in
a box
not my recipe
and then garlic bread and then she goes
now ryan come on i'll show you the rest
i go hold on
she goes well before we go anywhere i go
you made that sauce and she was yeah i
go
no you didn't she goes yes i did jason i
go no
mom i lived with you for 24 years you
never made a sock all of a sudden you're
making sauce
she goes well i did make it jason and i
go mom i'm not letting you leave this
kitchen until you
why are you putting the screws through
because it makes his own sauce because
what do we do we're just letting people
lie to our face now yeah larson get her
it's your mother man give her a [ __ ]
break
he's living in society so i go [ __ ]
simple with him she goes
i made the sauce jason i go ma i can't
accept that and she goes
you know what i ran out of sauce so i
had to use some jar
sauce too are you happy and then i
looked in the trash later four things of
jar sauce
what are we talking about classico what
was that no it was mixed up a little
preggo classico and i think there might
have been a rayo's in there for a kick
or rayo's
[Laughter]
that's a big question we had if you do
you seem like a guy who would make your
own sauce
am i being presumptuous here i can i
mean i have a really good recipe from a
friend of mine yeah if you do
if you are buying jar yeah what are you
going to do
i'm going to do but if it's you know i
have kids so i do both if i'm gonna make
my eggplant parm i'm buying rayos and
i'm gonna get [ __ ] from my friends that
i didn't make my own sauce but i don't
care
if i'm going for the kids i go classico
because being that i'm classy
i soak those bad boys and i use them for
glasses later yeah
you want to drink a lemonade out of a
regular no you want a mason jar yeah
yeah wow fresh mint in there you know
what i mean what is with a metal straw
before we go too far real quick before
we steer too far away what are you
putting out at the party apps
app wise you're coming you're coming
correct i think a charcuterie plate is
nice you know you do that
combos uh dude i'm not gonna lie
you know who i am you know who i am at
my core bro this is who i am
i'm gonna put all this out but when i'm
alone and i'm driving i stop at a gas
station and i'm getting pizza flavored
combos
i'm getting a soda i'm getting a [ __ ]
honey bun i'm getting a honey bun and
like a twix
and that's gonna be my ride to like the
pizza flavor combo is
you know that's a deep cut not many
people go the classic pretzel cheddar
no the pizza one the good one yeah yeah
yeah
one of man's greatest achievements
honestly and we're old enough to
remember i remember when combos hit
me too they [ __ ] chips and pretzels
are like get the [ __ ] out of here
back burner those things hit you know
what's funny is we never had combos in
my house and we never had pringles in my
house but if you went to my aunt roo's
house
that's where they were at and i knew the
[ __ ] cabinet they were in and she'd
have a she'd have a sleeve of pringles
and a sleeve of the cheese ones and i
was like
cheese move aside stop creaming i'm
getting you're going down
yeah that's them yeah you come with me
yeah
but charcuterie plates dope i like the
chips and guac you got no beef from to
me there i mean i wouldn't mind
something like some nice meatballs like
with a stick
sure i mean we were talking about a
crock pot listen i ain't even
you could do a crock pot i'm not gonna
get mad at you i make a cranberry
meatball no big deal
what's that about what's cranberry
meatball dope dude it's just like you
make meatballs right
and then you take jellied cranberry
sauce
cocktail sauce uh not cocktail sauce
like chili sauce it just looks like
cocktail sauce the heinz one
but it's not brown sugar lemon juice a
couple other things and you
mix it all up you put the meatballs in
you cover it with all this you bake it
like almost like swedish meatballs a
little bit a little bit yeah yeah right
um damn next next time you have a dinner
party i just want to come shadow you so
i can take notes oh yeah
yeah you can do that yeah um why don't
you just come and hang oh i could do
that too but i want to learn i want i
don't want to be in the experience i
want to i got to pick up some of these
hips for your top patreon people west
coast
come out we do with dinner yeah we're
we're going yeah we're going to larson's
um but i think you're good with all that
and i don't even care if you go to
trader joe's you know they have so many
of those apps you can just pay by
they do it all right that's it throw
that in i'm gonna be happy if i show up
at your party and that's what you're
kicking
shrimp cocktail sure i mean it gets a
little pricey and it's not for everybody
and it gives a leftover stench
dude i love how he immediately has an
opinion a well thought out opinion on
everything
i love shrimp cocktail yeah that used to
be a go-to move with
when we cooked together me and my wife i
would get some just for making dinner my
favorite thing
nothing no better way to kick it with a
girl than like have a little snack that
you're eating together
oh that's the best that's the best part
of making dinner yeah
one of my favorite things is going out
to dinner with my girlfriend and having
a couple drinks in the apps in the
beginning
but i mean you know what's even true
yeah you know what i like doing
that somewhere else you go to one spot
for drinks and amps and then you
especially new york you walk to
somewhere else
whoa this guy he's like i sit down
i'm here for the night okay i'll leave a
breakfast menu will you tony
i'm also a hardcore bar guy you know
what yeah i like to sit at the bar and
eat my dinner there i don't want to go
at the bar talk with the bartender other
people coming up you're rapping
are you a counter guy at the at the
diner come on bro
all day at the counter yeah i'm drinking
my coffee
some sassy waitress all right yeah yeah
yeah i got the pen i've got her down
[ __ ] cheer up a little bit uh do you
have a favorite bar in new
york i mean i have a favorite restaurant
what is it i went i
literally landed excuse me last thursd
friday i left my hotel walked right
there little frankie's
my favorite oh one second is that on
second first first avenue
dude you want to see this is where i
this is your favorite restaurant in all
of new york yeah the spaghetti lemon
is the greatest oh i saw a picture of it
yeah yeah yeah
insane yeah and i make it at home but
you take one bite and it's just like
crushes
but everything he does there crushes i
put it this way this is the where i
this is where i teed it from classy to
[ __ ] trash yeah cause that's not like
the nicest place no but yeah it's not
nice at all it's kind of a dive
i mean last night i took myself out to
this french restaurant and i had pate
and then i had baked lobster and like a
bechamel
with mashed potatoes i mean come on you
go
on solo take yourself out to dinner yeah
i love french man that's nice
yeah so it was nice did that right
before the village it was like right
around the corner from village
underground
oh but like little frankie's one time i
went in there
we always get me and my buddy used to
get this like he does thin pizza with
uh um ricotta
prosciutto see how we hit that everybody
wear that oh yeah yeah and then
truffle and then it's another layer of
dough over it and he bakes it and we
have that as an app
then i go spaghetti lemon then i go the
panna cotta okay they have my reddy on
tap
i'm going there when in rome i'm getting
them ready on tap maybe i'll have a
couple whiskeys
who's more ready i'm ready it's a beer
bro
the guy who's already the guy that
killed gandolfini
one night i was in there and i was
leaving new york the next day and we we
got there like 11 30 and then it was
like one and they go guys we're closing
the kitchen anything else i'm like let
me hit that spaghetti lemonade again
[Laughter]
at the end two different dinners at the
same place same dinner
same time dinner twice dude this guy's
coming in like the coach of class he's
like boys taking
no no i got the halftime speech cooking
something else will you put out a
dessert
for this uh this affair this party i
might have sweet sled this is where you
have a chance to be fun this is where
you have a chance to include
everybody you know what i mean okay this
is a chance where you can go
set up a sundae bar it's not tough you
just get a pint of ice cream you got the
scoop the whipped cream the chocolate
no one's going to care if it's fancy
chocolate they're going to want the
syrup from
you know what i mean hershey's here you
do something like that okay one of the
greatest power
you want to hear a [ __ ] power move
one time i'm at a party in the hollywood
hills
i was only there because i had a friend
of a friend of a friend right i'm like
27.
i'm in there i'm in the kitchen they had
a chef right they had a bartender
outside
i'm in there in the kitchen eating some
food and this guy comes up to me he's
like hey man
and i go hey man and he goes who do you
know and i go my friend tracy knows this
girl who knows the guy
and he goes all right like what about
you he goes nobody i just crashed
he goes yeah welcome bro right
he breaks off from me i break off it's
about an hour and a half later
they've broken down the kitchen they've
like cleaned up from dinner everyone's
having a drink i'm in the kitchen
and i see this guy coming in he's got a
shirt folded up like this
and in the tree that was uh in the yard
there was an apricot tree right
he comes in the kitchen he drops a pile
of apricots
on the kitchen counter looks the chef
and goes iron chef dude what's up this
is a guy who crashed this thing
hardy 15 minutes later bowls of ice
cream with caramelized apricots going
around and i went up to that guy i'm
like you're the [ __ ]
coolest guy here that guy should be in
every part holy [ __ ] so listen if you
have access to a little burner maybe we
do
maybe you do marshall you do uh s'mores
with people if you've got a fire going
pretty good if you can do a make your
own sunday sure otherwise yeah
have something sweet you know like the
andes you know what i mean
drop a drop a pack of andes on these you
know what i mean i don't know but uh
what did you guys throw out there for
dessert
mini cupcakes mm-hmm yeah
i think we said if there was a plate if
there's a little bit you got a problem
with the mini cupcake i do
well i got a big problem because
cupcakes splashed on the scene like 12
years ago
and then everybody had a cupcake shop
and everyone brings them and guess what
it's usually this much cake
and this much frosting and it's too much
it's [ __ ] too much frosting oh i love
that
i don't hate it i'd go just frosting you
know how you're supposed to eat a
cupcake
rip the bottom off make a sandwich is
that true
wow he just [ __ ] leaves
the cameras i was the guy at that party
yeah man that's what you're supposed to
do just to pull it off and bow make a
sandwich
but there's so much frosting it's too
much it's the best it's just blowing my
mind cut the bottom off
i don't get what half it and then yeah
really
is that like how they were designed or
that's just what people figured out no
but someone presented that to me
damn that's just what you do if you
[ __ ] know what's up dude yeah clearly
i never knew would you go to finishing
school yeah what the [ __ ] you're the
biggest bosses
that's finishing school that's how
[ __ ] shitty
you are gang real quick want to talk to
you about our good friends over there at
stamps.com the best
let's talk about this let's do it
pandemic starting to get put in our rear
view mirror
summer's in full full bloom down here
getting back to normal baby things are
getting back to normal
things you like doing some things not so
much yeah you know what i mean you don't
want to waste too much time at the post
office
nah i don't want to be standing in there
summertime nice out no so use stamps.com
stamps.com you can mail ship right from
your office you do it all right on your
computer
they send you a printer they give you
deals at ups
they give you deals at usps all right
it's a no-brainer
yeah they're saving people tons of money
yeah guys uh
i mean we have a lot of small business
owners that listen to the show yes we do
we use stamps.com to
send out all the cards all the merch
it's fantastic we do it right here
at hoodies get they send you the printer
they send you the stuff you bing bang
boom plug it in
print it up lick it and stick it baby
out the door you can set up
pickups if you want if you got a lot of
stuff we live right next to the
we're right down the street from the
post office we mosey over with a bag of
stuff dump it in dump it out and we're
in and out
ten seconds ten seconds and we just want
the fresh air that's why we're doing it
yep
yeah um so guys it's a no-brainer saving
nearly one million small businesses
uh like you time and money they offer
deals you can't get anywhere else up to
40
off usps up to 66 off ups
what what are we even doing here can't
afford to pass this upstairs getting
over
50s is bonkers uh and with their
switch and save feature you can compare
other carriers to find the best rates at
any time guys so stop
wasting time to go to the post office go
to stamps.com instead
there's no risk at all and with our
promo code garbage you'll get a special
offer that includes four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
fantastic they sent it to us we
we we even got the free package it's
right no long term commitments or
contract go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
type in garbage one more time at
stamps.com promo code garbagestamps.com
never go to the post office again gang
we're here to talk to you about fume who
dat
right here fume kippy our good pals good
pal canadian maid wooden inhaler
with the power of super plan hand
crafted
hand crafted absolutely fantastic
uh nicotine alternative allergies
relaxation whatever you need they got it
yeah guys it works with the
hand-to-mouth habit you know
the the oral fixation as you say the
nicotine cravings the menthol cravings
the stress of quitting the stress of
quitting smoking
smells so good i know they're kind it's
the conquer cure they call it uh
it's the number one core for quitting
smoking from start to finish
and they taste great too they have a
unique minty earthy sweet mix of flavors
good blend
yeah right um the conker is infused with
black pepper to ease nicotine cravings
peppermint for cooling menthol sensation
and lavender
to ease the whole process good stuff
folks uh they sent us a bunch like i've
said they've been sending it to us like
almost monthly at this point when we're
in the studio and i need a bernie
instead of
instead of going downstairs and having
one i'm hitting the fume baby taking it
taking an edge off
naturally um so head to breezefume.com
check out their quit naturally pack
it comes with one fume uh two packs of
the conquer cures and you get your
journey
to breathing free of addiction nice uh
make sure to let them know we sent you
to garbage boys by using the promo code
garbage
for 10 off your order today 10 off your
order
today um the link will be in the
description of the episode
uh it's like we said canadian made
worldwide shipping 30 plus customers sir
30 000 plus customers serve uh nearly a
five star rating
uh all the testimonials on the website
everything so one more everybody loves
it head to breathefume.com that's
breathefumefum.com or click the link in
the description use promo code garbage
10 off quit smoking or vaping today now
back
to the show okay what about this i was
thinking about this on the way out of
here yeah
as as a sweet snack just to have out
maybe the whole time
how do you feel about a caramel
chocolate
popcorn combo
you just went from the top what are you
talking about you're gonna bust out a
three-layer tin with the cheddar thank
you what is it
toss it in a bowl hey man i am what i am
i'm not here to lie you just
killed you got the light you should have
walked off stage the thunderous
tried out a new bit at the end of the
stride yeah
here's my problem fly me to the moon i
do like that like really good popcorn
like that but
if you're leaving it out all day it
doesn't give it there's no kicker at the
end
people want that sweet when they've been
going savory all day you know what i
mean
i don't mind i don't mind pre-making a
chocolate chip cookie dough
and then like later whenever like no
one's eating food you're popping it in
the oven while people are hanging out
everyone's smelling it they're like hot
cookies coming out of the oven forget it
that's the thing you can't teach that
yeah that is so [ __ ] classy
and it's just those little extra steps
that make it [ __ ] nice make it
homemade yeah yeah that's really
they can be deliberately it could be
pillsbury cookies it doesn't matter
right it doesn't matter you're cranking
on [ __ ] fresh cookies you're looking
forward smell it dude dude you got like
six high balls in here next thing you
know you smell some [ __ ]
i didn't understand the last six words
he said an aperitif is something you
have before dinner
i know or you know steve or an amar i
mean i love amaros
you know what other restaurant i like in
in new york is freeman's i don't like
being
dressed up freeman's is good raymond's
is dope food's not as good as like
frank's little frankie's yeah but it was
pricey too when i was there yeah it was
like a 55
meatloaf or something yeah it was crazy
i was gonna get married i was gonna have
my wedding there oh really but it was
uh we were gonna get the room upstairs
but it was just too small for them
yeah yeah yeah and they went with
chipotle instead i went to the play
place at mcdonald's
you a chex mix guy of when
that's a no that is a no hey i'll be an
anything guy but it's all circumstantial
you know what i mean if i'm like
you know if i'm having uh guests over
the first time i don't know if i'm
throwing a checks next
but if i'm having the boys over to watch
football on a sunday i don't mind it
checks max i mean i'm still going to do
something nice you're going to be going
to larson
you're going to you're going to lie
that's good you're going to launch them
yeah i like it
all right all right we got the score
taken care of that was fantastic we're
gonna get to some patreon questions
we have a couple of our own that we
wanted to ask you
because of your class that we maybe
never got to
yeah kevin i have one now uh this is a
big one we go to
obviously one of the big questions we
ask is we do have a lot of [ __ ]
hobo comics coming right you know that
aren't that aren't as a steam gentleman
as yourself mr larson
but they're not little frankie's
material yeah um what
we typically have some if they have it
like say they had a they found out they
were going to a wedding tomorrow do they
have a proper suit that fits
shoes belt tie obviously you do
uh-huh probably have mo my question is
how many suits do you have
i have three you have three suits from
those colors well one is
i'll start with the seersucker
[Laughter]
you ready for this bro why did he look
at his nails
i don't know he grabbed a minute i'd
never get him i would never get a
manicure in my life right
i pegged you as a man the nails look
great thanks man that's all teeth
i went to a wedding in the bahamas in
jamaica
at round hill which is like this super
fancy place my buddy's
my buddy's from atlanta and his whole
family's like sec
guys you know what i mean those are
southern gentlemen [ __ ] this was the
wedding in southern general so i'm like
that's the boston in them i was like you
can't go to a southern wedding
and granted it was in the bahamas or
jamaica and not so i got a seersucker
suit you can't be wearing a black
black suit there right they're coming
correct peop everyone was
it was it was black tie ah and i said
no i'm wearing seersucker got the
got the bow tie can you wear a
seersucker to black tie yeah you can
i mean i did i can't i don't know about
you but i go down so i got the bow tie
and i didn't get a clip on i got a real
bow tie yeah you know how to tie it
i had to learn yeah it's time wow you
should learn something i can't get my i
can never get it right
yeah i punched a wall yeah i'm trying to
learn like i'm [ __ ] doing it you're
watching the video yeah so i figured it
out right i go down the wedding
and i immediately i'm next to like three
dudes that are friends of the father of
the groom and they're all
sec georgia clemson whatever right
they're all there all in in bow ties and
cummerbunds right
their buddy comes down he's got the
cummerbund on holding his bow tie and he
comes in he goes hey do you guys know
how to tie a bow tie and
all three guys go no these are just like
clip arounds
and then the guy looks at me and he goes
what about you i'm like oh yeah this i
tied it and he goes do you know how to
tie i don't know how to tie one and i go
sure
so i'm tying it on him and i just stop
and i go are you telling me
that amongst four southern gentlemen it
takes a yankee
to tie a bow tie and these guys got
pissed like i went to
i went to georgia tech and i was just
like whatever you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
kick rocks dork yeah all right you and
your clip-on making friends at the
wedding huh
and then i just have to leave i have a
navy suit classic and then
that's a knock-around yeah and then i
have a i have an all black
suit when i was doing the twin peaks
premiere i'm like i need a black suit so
i just went and got a black suit yeah
nice but none of it's really fitting
right now you know what are you
right there with you good friends
getting married yeah okay first time
first time getting married mm-hmm
what are you what are you what are you
sneaking what was that by the way what
do you mean
you think you're talking to a guy's
divorce you got to drop first time get
there
because we're older yeah yeah no we're
older so it's not like it's not like a
small wedding it's like it's like a
wedding wedding
what are you dropping oh you mean as a
gift and again the card this is
this is what's in there i think 300 is
good 300. that's a gentleman's move
gentleman's move see you he has the vibe
you have the vibe that i feel like you'd
be around 152. i'm a two guy now that
we're making a couple of bucks
he just called you a loser you know what
i feel like he is he's the guy that
shows up in like an 89 corolla but puts
five honey in you know what i mean he's
got
no money he's like and he's telling
everyone at the wedding i slipped five
in the case
it's the first time oh no don't forget
there's five bills
he's like he's the guy who says five but
it's really 250. that's his move
hold on i'm 500 i put 500 in there let
me tell you this we just got our first
little bit of money yeah over like the
last like last couple of months
first thing i did is i went out and
bought my mom a two thousand dollar
necklace
two thousand dollars what thirteen
hundreds that's scary right there
i saw the receipt thirteen forty five
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you bought her a necklace that's just a
necklace
he's like it's a 1300 necklace that he
got like a [ __ ] little
not [ __ ] on it but then he goes yeah
we're probably gonna have to get a safe
deposit box or something to keep this i
go for the 1300 you're all right my god
my mother told me the other day she's
got to save the pause box i go what do
you have in there
what do you have and then she goes you
know papers i go what are you kramer you
have
papers in a safety deposit box i go when
was the last time she
you used it she was like well i got it
in 1987.
the problem is i don't know where the
key is i go just because you've never
used it yeah yeah there's nothing yeah
of course
what do you put in the safety deposit
box cash if you're a drug dealer
something like that yeah but you can't
even get to it do you have one
no i i don't and i don't have a d to my
house a deed maybe
oh yeah they put the d i think that's
the thing you put a deed in there
passports gun
what do you mean you can't get out i
can't get past portals if you need cash
you're gonna need to get to it quick if
you need a gun you're gonna need to get
to a quick right
you're not getting in the car and
driving yeah finding some other guy to
turn his key with i gotta run down the
chase real quick i'll be right back
and when i get back here you're [ __ ]
dead
and i love that these are the same
deposit box that chase hold on let me go
down this capital one cafe
i'm gonna grab a loft day and then and
then
why what's what's the safety deposit
back is there special ones
i just don't know if chase has i mean i
just can't imagine going into that room
with two kids you're standing in line at
a td
waiting for the next teller two guys
that i said
listen my atm card isn't working again
where's the slip for the safe deposit
but you got a pen i could borrow two
oh [ __ ] that is good stuff all right 300
300
that's classy yeah yeah yeah that's good
have you ever had to hire a private
investigator for any reason
because if you are you're probably doing
something you shouldn't be i want to
have but i never have yeah i wish i
could
i will i you know how badly i want to i
want to be in a parked car and pull up
next to him so our driver's windows are
facing
and he hands me a file he's like you're
not gonna like what you're seeing
i want that so bad i would love to i
just don't have anything in my life that
i would need
and i want to see if they could do a
better job than i would do you know
but no i never have i want to though
maybe someday you know
okay oh god that's too funny um
all right uh when was the this is when
was the last time you were in a beef
with a neighbor or are you currently in
a beef with an egg
currently no ah i will tell you this
there's been beef with our neighbor
growing up from we were kids
my whole life really so like yeah yeah
with your mom
like shakespeare [ __ ] yeah oh my god and
they're never moving out now
three generations are living in that
house next door now you know my mother
has a big yard
okay it's like an acre okay mass right
yeah and in my town that's like the
biggest yard in town
and they have a big yard too and it was
always going to be like well could we
build houses back there
i've talked to them this was the story
it is still going on yeah
you know what i mean um i had beef with
the neighbor once because he wouldn't
give me a jump
i asked him for a jump and he wouldn't
give me a jump and i was like how can
you not give me a jump
you know what i mean right now yeah he
said no straight to my face
he says it's not good for his car he's
like that's not good for my car
you gotta understand though i love
confrontation so i love getting into
with people because i don't
feel uncomfortable when i'm telling
someone exactly how i feel
you know what i mean so i'm not
currently in beef with him but i have no
problem
airing it out no problem saying anything
to anyone if they
i did hear a neighbor in my new house uh
really i mean this isn't really funny
really belittling his child and
screaming at him
and i it was getting to me bad and it
was getting bad
like his kid was crying and he's just
yelling at him to pick up a plate or
something
and i just go to my yard and i was like
hey and he just kept going he never
heard me
so i'm like i'm just waiting have you
ever met this guy before you ever i've
only lived there a month and a half so
i'm waiting and see if it comes up a
second
this isn't the past month and a half
yeah if it comes up a second time i'm
definitely going over the house and i'm
going to say something be like yo man
uh you know that kid can't really defend
himself so next time you have that kind
of [ __ ]
like call me i'll come back and let's
just sort at me and you can come i'm not
my daughter yelling at my life really
yeah because it was bad you look like
you can handle yourself i know you're
good
i think that yeah thanks
what's your favorite beef you've ever
been in do you have one that stands out
my favorite beef [ __ ]
let me see i mean it might take me a
minute to like yeah i want to know what
happened with the
the with the what kind of car was it
that you know i had i had
a uh i bought how long ago was it you'll
like this
i bought a ninth i bought a 2 000
ford explorer okay my best friend at
brunch one day
because he was gonna leave brunch i'm
like where are you going he goes like i
gotta go to carfax and get rid of the
explorer i'm like get the [ __ ] out of
here
go do it another days like i gotta do it
today blah blah i'm getting the other
car
and i was like how much you getting from
carfax carfax or whatever the place is
and he goes uh they give me two grand
and i was like two grand i got that on
me i go
i at the time i look at my my fiance and
i was like what do you think and i'm
like i need a car and he's like i'll
give it to your 1500
if i don't have to leave here right now
1500 i go done deal i drove that car for
eight years eight years to the point
where this window wouldn't go down
and this door wouldn't open so i had to
roll down the back window i was doing a
movie
shooting a movie and i'd show up on set
and my friend who was the lead was like
dude i knew we were going to be friends
when i saw you opening your car door
that way jesus and then finally
i was like consulting on crashing and
like you'd go to apatow's production
company that was this was like
you had this up until a couple of years
then correct what the [ __ ] yeah
three years ago jesus yeah maybe four
that was your only call
but i but you gotta understand some
about me i've never given a [ __ ]
i know yeah it doesn't matter to me so i
had that
and i was in we're in a writer's meeting
and talking about hbo over here
not even tv that's hbo you couldn't get
hbo in this basement
that's a subscription based channel so
the pa comes in he's like jay can i get
the keys car i need to move it and i was
like
literally the anxiety was like oh you're
poor
i don't have a car the next day we head
off i went out and bought a beamer
yeah yeah yeah i love that yeah and i
got divorced and i got rid of it
like two months ago i had a 2004 2005
mercury montego
beat up like [ __ ] it was a new york
city car for
five years so it's just like hit by a
bus oh it's all crunched up
windows don't work air doesn't work
radio doesn't work and we went to i had
to get a i went to like a really nice
spa with my wife for our anniversary
and i was dreading for like the week i'm
like hopefully they don't make me valet
this thing because it's a top there's
like trash it's just a bad look
and i pull up and they're like uh yeah
pull right in here for the valley i'm
like not do it myself man
yeah totally there was an air
conditioner in the trunk there was an
air con
window unit in the trunk no there wasn't
but it wasn't installed
hey turn on the ac honey she's gonna
crawl over two rows of seats [ __ ]
coming up to the front looks like the
cabbies do now yeah yeah
you'd be chilly in there though with a
[ __ ] window oh yeah cranking that
thing up
hold on i'm fascinated by the jump thing
yeah
he doesn't do it that's it everybody
just walks away that was it
it got uncomfortable did you ever speak
to that guy yeah of course
but like he would avoid oh this is what
ended up happening so he avoided me
and i avoided him for like two months
then one saturday night
a car goes flying down our street right
it's about 9 30
saturday night flying ripping down the
street
and i look at my wife and i go holy [ __ ]
that guy's moving and then
we just heard a uh crash
i run out i pass his house i see my
other neighbor we get down
and there's like this escalade had just
slammed into a car they backed out and
then they
drove away it's always an escalade i
feel like yeah
yeah they drove away and i guess what i
found later is they gave the finger to
the owners that came out and were just
like this the whole way
but the front right tire was couldn't
move because it was jammed
so when they got driving off it was just
like
you could hear where it was going yeah
yeah so then when we got back to the
house
i'm walking back to my house i see the
guy nick who i hadn't talked to in
months getting into his cargo what are
you doing he's like nothing i go looks
like you're doing something
and he's like well i'm gonna go follow
those guys see if i can follow that
sound and find out who it is
and then like 45 minutes later he came
home his wife opened the fence to their
backyard
right which doesn't have a driveway and
he pulled his car in
and my wife at times like what are they
doing i'm like he's hiding his car in
his car
so that if they come back looking for
him he found those guys and she was like
oh my god
and uh i do this as a bit right so
that's where the story ended but it
might vid
i later put a note on his door that says
i know it was you
uh i [ __ ] what is it i know i know it
was you
you [ __ ] with the wrong guy i'm gonna
kill your wife that was like
what i had decided i told my wife that's
what i was gonna do and she's like no
[ __ ] way that yeah yeah and uh [ __ ]
yeah you know it's like i know what you
did last summer
god damn he puts out a good charcuterie
report but this guy's [ __ ]
but i do like [ __ ] with i mean that's
part of my life is i love [ __ ] with
people when we got when we had our first
kid
the the our ob gyn we went into the
first meeting you sit in his office he's
[ __ ] with doctors
what are you about to tell us we sit
down at his desk and he's got like a
he's got this trophy right like it
looked like an oscar like an oscar award
and we sit down and he goes look at this
and i'm like what and he goes the trophy
and it says world's best grandfather and
i was like oh cool he goes
must be true yeah i'm the best that's
his bit yeah so i [ __ ] went out got
an oscar made
world's best grandfather runner-up and
one day when my wife is in with him i
snuck out switched him hid his
never said anything put a note on the
bottom i go runner up ain't bad love the
larson's just left it on his desk
never said anything then he switched it
it was up on his
the other my trophy was up there and his
was back
never say anything we going for the
second kid we sit down he goes look at
this
we go oh yeah no we know the trophy goes
no no the mug and he's got a mug his
grandkids made
my and sister sister's in pottery yeah i
took pictures dimensions sent her to her
she made
the same thing world's best grandfather
runner up switched him
he never said anything offered me water
the last time he visited him he's like
you want a water
you want he's trying to play something
with me never did anything
so then i got a shirt made world's best
grandfather runner-up
and i know his son because his son's in
comedy and i was like yo
would you do me a favor and stash this
in your dad's drawer at home
this guy's bob what are you loki
[Applause]
basically the kid was like dude i don't
feel comfortable doing that to my dad
he's like ray donovan of pranks
this is crazy he's an old man
[Laughter]
oh my god you have champagne flutes i
would assume
no oh he's got the white i got the coops
i forgot the name they were my aunt lils
they were like from 1910 they got
the thing the gatsby's hold like great
guys yeah etched glass no i got you
and then a bulb stem usually you get a
bulb stem but not etched glass or etched
glass and not a bulb stem i got them
both
they're very expensive they're from 1910
i mean maybe earlier my aunt lil
died at 102 and she died like
10 11 years ago something like that was
that a real
i don't know if it is uh yeah it's like
the [ __ ] is the trashy way to say to
zane
like my aunt patty my aunt patty yeah
it's
it's not classy what about a vitamix you
got a vitamix a vitamix was it like a
blender the big blender
yeah but i lost that in the divorce
i just i didn't take it i just left it
you know i mean i was like yeah i'm not
gonna take that
uh when was the last time you ate with a
chilled salad fork
ah i have no idea you gotta go to a nice
spot for a chilled salad yeah
caviar i mean i would do it i got
invited since i've been in new york i
got this guy who's a
fan and uh he works at a high-end
restaurant and he's like why don't you
come out to the restaurant or you can go
to my girls
she works at a caviar tasting spot i got
invited out but didn't pull the trigger
you know what i mean
what kind of circles this guy running i
don't know people when they
you like cool [ __ ] so people go hey i
got cool [ __ ] come check out my cool
[ __ ]
totally damn bought a car at brunch you
know one time
i take the eggs benny and they get crazy
who does that
dude i one time was doing a show seemed
like a guy who says eggs benny
i yeah i would but i don't even get eggs
benny you know what i mean
is too much you know what too rich oh i
don't get enough of it
yeah trust me i know you asked him to
bring out like a little [ __ ]
oh i got an extra side yeah i gotta sign
outside of uh hollandaise sauce
to put on my home fries what am i jerk
golf i'm gonna use ketchup
dude i did a show in dc once in a girl
came up to me and she's like you come
out to this restaurant my dad owns it
blah blah so i go
with my friend she waits on us i have
this amazing meal she's super cool
and then like towards the end of the
meal she's gone
and then someone else is waiting always
and i go hey always dicey
this is actually a question from a
patreon member and they're like yeah she
went home sick and i'm like really i go
can i talk to your manager
manager comes over and i'm like hey man
i'm like what happened he's like oh she
went home sick
and i'm like huh she doesn't say nothing
to you and i look over my friend and i
go
he's lying to us she did not go home
sick this is
insane and he goes we had to let her go
and i go because of us
and she's like he's like no it's just
and i go because she said she was paying
for this meal yeah she's like nah man
and we had to pay for the meal do you
think she got let go because they were
like i need to comp table 32
or whatever he's like not [ __ ] again
yeah you know what i mean we're not
doing that
yeah exactly i never thought of that oh
her dad didn't own the joint
clearly if your dad's only you don't get
fired mid-shift when you're done
yeah you get a side after and then gives
you a fifth chance
that's tough love right there i'll tell
you that at least finishing the table
out they're not you're not booting the
daughter mid-table
wow um all right i got one new york city
summertime you walk outside you're
feeling pretty good right
uh ice cream truck pulls up you're
allowed one item
off the ice cream truck what do you mean
now we're getting into all right i'm a
traditionalist all right so listen don't
be coming at me with the [ __ ]
rocket you know what i mean the [ __ ]
red white and blue rock get
that [ __ ] out those are great though and
i don't i don't want a chocolate chip
cookie sandwich
i want straight up ice cream sandwich
you know what it is yeah classic classic
ice cream sandwich you know what i mean
van dyke you cloned it guy i'm not i
said traditionally
i don't need that new age [ __ ] i'm
never gonna get mad at a klondike bar
but like i do we do have those standards
that we go to it like an ice cream if
and i first of all
if i pass a lemonade stand the kids
selling i stop
every single time really oh yeah and i
always pay way more than it costs
if an ice cream truck goes by i don't
give a [ __ ] what i'm doing i go out and
i stop them and i get ice cream and if
anyone else is there i'm buying
you know what do you mean like the
people waiting yeah well i mean
no if kids come on the street you're
like i got it you know what yeah you
know that's what you do
really you're an adult and there are
kids there yeah dude [ __ ]
first time i ever saw someone went to a
wedding in savannah this guy's [ __ ]
top notch my buddy's friend who came
from money right
and he's like knows he did we go in
after the rehearsals in this ice cream
shop in savannah georgia
and he sits down next to this father and
son he's like what are you eating kid
in a suit legs crossed he goes what do
you eat and he goes yeah kid tells me is
it good he goes yeah a guy stands up and
goes
i'm buying everyone's ice cream and
bought the entire place and i was just
like
i want to do that yeah cause that
probably cost him what
maybe a hundred and twenty bucks yeah
yeah
i mean dude your mom's necklace was
three grand
dude you gotta save this episode or
whatever episode you mentioned it
because in five years from now that
necklace is gonna be 12 grand
first year i bought a five thousand
dollar necklace and a choco taco
yeah holy [ __ ] what's your go-to with an
ice cream uh
truck i'm sorry please should it please
the choco taco or the screw ball would
be mine but if it's a if it's
this guy is a [ __ ] screwball all
right if it's a mr softy
i'm getting a twist with rainbow
sprinkles like a [ __ ] gentleman
i'm getting a crunch coat i mean i got
it twice when i was back home what's a
crunch coat you know it's like vanilla
chocolate swirl oh
and then i go crunch coke you think you
know a guy what's a crunch coat a lot of
places don't have it
not new yeah in new york they do not a
big ice cream guy get off my case what
do you want listen we all know you
you probably got a crunch coat on you
right now all right relax
i got my own spooning it over with this
underwear crunch
that used to blow me away when i was a
kid when they lay it flat oh when they
were
just doing the sprinkles this guy
[ __ ] magician how's he doing there
what about you what's your go-to in the
truck i would go ice cream sandwiches
classic just had one at home i was down
to shore shout out to wildwood new
jersey and then
my mom had it for the kids she had the
cookies and cream in the middle which
first time having it
not too shabby i got it for my kids in
the freezer
good stuff mickey mouse face with the
cookies and cream inside yeah that's
time but i'm a big chip witch too i
don't mind it chip which love it
it's gotta be a good tempt though
sometimes they're [ __ ] it's like an
iceberg in the background oh can
you can't get your teeth through let me
just tell you this find out you got
cavities real quick you know what then
you sure do i have the ice cream
sandwiches in my freezer for the kids
and sometimes when they go to sleep i go
out i'll watch sportscenter i bring out
the ice cream sandwich
i leave it right there next to me for a
solid two and a half minutes yeah i
gotta get the right temperatures
that's the thing you have to let it rest
for a little while yeah
it's like a steak yeah just just like it
just like slipped over juice kobe beef
just like
wrap it in tin foil let it sit there do
you sleep in pajamas
no yeah do you sleep with a fan directly
on you
uh i'm not mad at it i don't have one in
my room currently but i love a ceiling
fan
how many pillows do you use to sleep in
i have two and i alternate
two behind the head well i mean two like
they'll be like this and then
i'll be like here and i move over to
that side sometimes so i can't be
elevated too high with the head
what not one between your legs or
holding one no sometimes but then i'll
just bring it back up and usually end up
with it under the head
yeah pretty good classic everybody ever
been to a bacon brothers concert
i don't even know who they are kevin
bacon and his brother are like they do
blues or something [ __ ]
them i played some i played some of the
same venues as them
uh which is not good for either one of
us i don't think
um all right how long will you use the
same towel to dry yourself off after a
shower you're doing like a week
every day what do you swear how long are
you sweating i'd say
four days it's good it's good four days
all the towels match yeah
the kids have matching towels i got
matching really yeah what color are we
talking about gray i'm straight gray
really the man it's the it's the manly
it's the manly color i got my kids like
snoopy ones
all white with a little snoopy and
woodstock on them each got one yeah
that's pretty sweet you know what i mean
snoopy's already
got to make them feel like it's their
[ __ ] sure of course
that's good yeah it doesn't bother me
i don't need you taking your shoes off
when you get it i think that's actually
trashier than keeping them on yes when
you keep them on you're like [ __ ] it
what do i give a [ __ ] i'll get a new rug
if i want
yeah i don't i just feel like i don't
ever want to live my life
so stuffy that it's not you know i want
everything to be utilitarian
you know what i mean you want to like
just live you know have you ever gone to
someone's house for a dinner party for
saying they were like shoes off at the
door
yes but yeah and you have to have you
seen that sebastian bit
no oh my god you never said oh yeah he
never thought it's great i don't think
so he's like i get in the guy goes hey
you mind taking your shoes off he's like
take my shoes off
and then he goes now he goes he's like
hopping on one foot taking he's like so
how long you guys live here
i'm talking to other grown men with
their socks yeah
that's good it's great yeah oh he asked
chad's momma terry that and i go
if he goes will you take it off because
who was the classiest guy in the world
everything he did was a new level of
class that we'd never even thought of
we asked him like will you take your
shoes off he goes i will it's the last
time we're going there though i'll do it
but
last time he goes i'll do it just
because i'm never coming back
let me tell you something mr j larson
yeah you're right there you're right
you're [ __ ] right there that's high
class you're the second classiest person
that's ever been on the show i love it
ah i'll tell you this about sebastian
one time like years ago i sat in his car
like we're in the driving
driving uh driveway at the commie store
and there were cigarettes
in this thing and i go you smokey just
no i just have them in case a girl does
oh i was just like oh what
keeping bernie's in the car for the
ladies yeah
holy [ __ ] next level that's like
preparation
wow dude he seems like he's yeah he's on
point yeah like his underwear are dry
cleaned
yeah he did that and wes what was it the
wild wild west comedy tour you would get
his
underwear dry cleaning really yeah yeah
i don't do that fresh
yeah no no would you have stuff you dry
clean you dry clean all day i never dry
cleaned until i met my wife
and then i would uh dry clean and i
haven't
i just went to the dry cleaner for the
first time in like two years
because i had stuff that i'm like these
like two wool sweaters and stuff like
that
you got a cashmere sweater at the house
yeah i like cashmere a lot yeah
[Laughter]
oh yeah i love fabric i used to go to
fabric stores with my mother as a kid
that's why she would take us and we have
to sit there and be in fabric stores
but we're we're in that writing room for
crashing greg fitzsimmons you know greg
he's been on the show yeah so he was he
was in the room
he's sitting next to him he's nuts and
uh pete holmes across the room goes greg
i like that sweater what is that
cashmere he goes yeah it's cashmere and
i'm just looking at i go that's cashmere
and he goes yeah i reach behind look at
the label and i just sit back down i go
that's 70 cotton 30 cashmere
that's not your mom with the sauce i can
see it yeah you know what i mean let's
just be what we are that's
cashmere coated that's a crunch that's a
crunch
crunch cashmere are you a cologne guy
i have one i barely wear it i got it
with my brother
in p-town you know p-town in
massachusetts what's p-town
yeah uh providence providence town
provincetown yeah
and uh i got it one time i was home with
him you know my brother's into cologne
and i got this nice stuff but i
you know i would wear it if i was just
going to do shows i haven't worn it in
like two years
okay you i'm a clone guy what do you got
i have i have a sample pack yeah you do
whatever was in the gq magazine it's
rubbing on his neck
like a cab whatever my dentist carries
whatever magazine sub
he's got that is insane got the johnny
depp one today
clone from a highlights magazine you
guys should make are you garbage
like a nice cologne you know you can get
it made and then you should just that
should be pretty good there you go
something musky and just doing a little
stamp smells like fried chicken
yeah it's just yeah it smells like
hangovers uh
credit cards american express card uh do
i have
no i don't no america no dude listen
being classy doesn't mean you got case
of course of course
it's not like i'm flush you know i've
never
i would never even call i didn't even
have a credit card until i got married
then i was just like oh i got to build
my credit yeah i mean
which we're we're doing where we just
started yeah my credit limits 200 bucks
okay yeah that's not great you can even
buy a necklace
i can't even buy my mother necklace
mine's 500. okay so
so you pay cash
i'm capital one baby my limited a little
what's your limit i think it's like 15
or something pretty good 15 grand
tell me you got 15 grand on you right
now holy [ __ ] i got 15k
on here what do you think that's the
rule i don't know my mother always said
you have as much money as your credit
limit will allow that's why mine's 200
man um well i mean you know when you
have a family there's certain times you
need to be able to buy things if you
need it
you got to be able to stick and move you
know what i mean you can't be like oh i
guess
i can survive without a car right now
you just need to be able to step up you
got to have that line of credit do you
always have a little bit of cash on you
i owe dude i love having like i love
having
five i think five's a nice number 500.5
yeah 500
300 to 500 i think is a nice number
that's ready for a wedding at any given
time just to have 500 cash on you yeah
i have since a pandemic i don't carry
cash anymore because no one was taking
no one
you can't even little frankie's gay show
yeah
yeah well dude i went in the other night
which is the finest that anytime it's
only cash oh
yeah they got good food if they take
cash and no reservations that place is a
[ __ ] gold mine well
there was a minute when i was in town
where they were taking credit cards so i
was just like oh pandemic they're
definitely taking credit cards i go in i
order my meal
and the guy goes all right and i go i
put a card down it's like oh we just
we're cash only and i go since when
and he goes we've always been cash there
wasn't a time when you weren't he goes
oh there was and my bill was like
with tip like 110 bucks you know
and i was like bro how are we going to
sort this i'm like my atm card doesn't
work
and he's like i go you have venmo and
he's like yeah i go how about i venmo
you and you cover it he's like all right
so i like
you know i gave a very heavy tip because
yeah yeah boom boom
you can't and i was in the service
industry if you ever worked in the
service industry
you know it doesn't matter what your
service was you got to just take care of
people
i was waiting tables up until two years
ago yeah i know
now i'm buying four thousand dollar
necklace
all right it's nice she's like i didn't
even need a necklace
she was gushing all right what do you
got from the patreon oh yeah we'll just
run through a couple and we gotta
get you out of here get on out of here
uh this is from jessa
uh anyone in your family ever won
something by calling into the radio
station
yeah [ __ ] me son not only did i call
well my sister called in once and won
tickets to go see the cars
and i took my friend i got to meet
robert smith backstage
really pretty tight but i once won a
radio car coming did you meet robert
smith
of the cure yeah with the radio station
yeah yeah where
where is he you said you were going to
the cars that's uh rick o'kasick
no oh i'm sorry you're right what is it
uh who is
your smith the cure okay look at that
right there
get this bomb out of here uh
so i met him backstage that's awesome
and i also won a radio contest once
like they used to like they saw me in my
town walking down the street pulled over
and they used to do this gorilla in the
morning
and i cheated on it she did they give
out a number in the morning
and then they find people and if you
know the number otherwise you have to
guess between a window
i made my guess a woman pulled up behind
the caravan
she's waving me down i go i'll be right
back i gotta go over there and they go
you can't go talk to that woman you're
in the middle of context i'm like it's
my aunt she's getting married in two
weeks
i'm in ninth grade go over she goes you
in the context i go yeah she goes you
know the number i go no she gives it to
me they get me on the air
i had already told them my number get me
on the air i give the number
she gave me they go nuts now they can't
take it away from you now they can't
take it away
she comes over the car they have to send
it to her because i don't know my social
security number i'm like 14 years old
and i won 11 hundy lodge holy [ __ ] it
was 36 after tax 22 i got to go 50 50
with her
and then you want
i took that money to marshalls to go
to go clothes shopping and the first day
of school
yellow silk shirt second day green silk
i wore
silk shirts back to back silk shirts
long sleeves first week hottest [ __ ]
like
for somebody who the [ __ ] wears long
sleeves oh man i was killing it
sweating damn that's crazy you never met
this woman before in your life
no and she knew you that you were doing
the radio kind of she saw because they
had the kiss 108 van you know what i
mean the whole black's pretty trashy man
knows i've since gone and done 108 the
guy that i
maddy in the morning he's been like the
radio host forever so i've done it when
i'm doing laugh boss and i was like dude
you know i cheated at a radio contest
with you he's like
we're gonna need that 36 hundo back um
all right this is from kyle uh how do
you feel about chilled beer glasses
uh a frosted mug yeah i'm at a buddy's
house and you bust out a frosted
game changer all day okay i used to have
them in my house but i wasn't drinking
beer on the reg you know what i mean and
there's certain beers you want in there
like a
you know like a corona pacifico
something like that you want in frost
that's a nice pole do you still booze a
little bit yeah but i just don't like
i'm not like uh
i'm not the guy who comes home and has a
steak and can't wait for that cold beer
but when a cold beer comes around you're
happy yeah you're good yeah
i have a beer question real quick yeah
la guy now yeah how do you feel about a
michelada i love a michelada but i
started liking micheladas when i worked
at the rusty knot on west 11th and west
side highway you know what i mean
but i but i i like it in like i like
taking a beer
salt lime and hot sauce in it and then
drinking that i don't know if i need to
go through the whole like
bring it out with a [ __ ] pickle and
an onion and an olive and [ __ ] like that
they're bones
yeah yeah what the [ __ ] are you two
talking about what's a michelada
guy's having a conversation right two
gentlemen yeah mitchellat it's like this
tomato in there and uh or just salt lime
and
hot sauce it's it's like it's almost
like a bloody mary it's like tajin
around the which is like a mexican
seasoning around the rim
and then they'll use like clamato or
tomato juice
a little bit of uh pickle juice
sometimes it's
amazing the cupcake sandwiches
enchiladas not bad he's on the verge of
class over here
i don't know i think i really blew it
with the popcorn question yeah that was
a bozo move there t-bone i'm just saying
i'm a little sweet out for the time
um all right let's do this let's wrap it
up with this this is from omar
how do you feel about a handkerchief or
a bandana to use blow your nose back in
the pocket
i will tell you this there was a time i
was opening for steve byrne on the road
and steve was like starting to like
really pop and he would wear a suit on
stage every night and i remember
we go out shopping the next day it's
always a suitcase and i go why
you start wearing a suit huh he goes
yeah i go you got a handkerchief in
there he goes no i go dude you gotta
have a handkerchief and so i bought him
like a pack of like cloth
nice handkerchiefs to have if you have a
suit you need a handkerchief
i'm not an old man you mean up here no
i'm saying to have inside in case you're
like sweating on stage you pull out a
nice handkerchief if you're with a lady
and she needs a handkerchief
you need to blow your nose sure but i'm
not going to be i'm not my grandfather
you're not carrying it in the pocket
every day and you're
in like jean shorts or something so
you're saying on a suit
on a suit jacket pocket you open that
pocket i'm saying
i always first of all i don't know the
inside it goes yeah inside he's not
talking about
but on the outside i will always have a
decorative handkerchief to match
whatever
the vibe is and if i'm not going thai i
still want something to give off a
little flare
and then inside you have the
handkerchief to offer to someone or for
your own
you know because kippy and i were going
back and forth he was saying outside
outside i don't open it they don't open
i don't know i don't open this pocket
yeah i keep it sealed because it
uh it tends to you know it gets haggard
looking
yeah well that's why you get new suits i
know what i mean which i'm doing
tomorrow actually
i currently do not get fit yeah yeah
yeah nice so what are you getting the
suit for
the wedding we talked about this we have
a wedding oh in germany
no in july i have one in germany as well
yeah oh they need a summer suit i need a
nice summer suit yeah what color you
going navy
no i got navy i got like the knock
around navy suit that i go i want to go
a little lighter i think i'm going like
light gray leg ray is nice i gotta get a
new suit for the same wedding what do
you think i should do
i think navy okay i said navy he also
doesn't have a suit
so you need a navy suit that's your
go-to shoe you can wear that to a
funeral
you can wear that to a event you can uh
you can go to an opening you can go to
anything
what's an opening you know like an art
exhibit or like anything
you know any place has an open sign
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen mr j larson buddy
thank you so much for sitting with us
baby uh is there anything you want the
folks have to know what do you got
coming up that's your camera right there
no
every nothing really now i i i uh co-ep
and direct all the sketches for the
connor moore show it's on golf pass if
you're into golf
check it out which are you dressed up
you're nice
looks like you should be on the tour
dude you know what i mean like a hat
shirt
everything's everything's touched yeah
and then i'm doing schumer's new show
that life and beth which is coming out
of hulu but that's
you know just keep an eye out for it
awesome fantastic what do you got for
him as always
you know if you subscribe itunes youtube
patreon and the live shows all the
information will be
in the description check that out can't
wait to see everybody on the road
what an episode this was so much fun for
us jay thank you so much for coming in
we love having you here we think you're
the best thank you and gang we love you
guys and we'll see you next week